[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا ومرحبا بكم في هذه
الحلقه من مقابله خاصه يسعدنا ان نستضيف
في حلقه اليوم معالي رئيس الوزراء فنلندا
السيده مريم بنرحب بيك طبعا في قناه
العربيه
جدا في الحلول الخضراء كيف يمكن الاستفاده
او استفاده العالم من التجربه الفنديه
وكيف يمكن ان تنقل الى الدول الناميه في
ظل وجود ازمه اقتصاديه وازمه التمويل وفي
ظل ايضا صراعات جيو سياسيه
من المشكلات الصعبه واكبرها هي مشكله
التغيير المناخي وتراجع التنوع البيولوجي
وعلينا جميعا التعامل مع هذه المسائل
سعيده ان انا هنا في كوب 27 لمحاربه هذه
التغيرات التي وعلى المناخ نحن في ذات
الوقت بحاجه الى التزام الدول بتنفيذ
مسؤوليتها لانه ما من دوله بمفردها قادره
على ذلك نحن بحاجه للتعاون والاتحاد من
اجل التوسل الى حلول مشتركه فللندا ستكون
جاهزه لتصبح دوله حياديه مناخيا بحلول
2035 وهذا مبكر جدا اذ نتحدث هنا عن عشر
سنوات كما لدينا اهداف طموحه نعمل على
تحقيقها حاليا وطريقنا لمحاربه التغيير
المناخي ياتي عبر التعاون اي التعاون بين
القطاع العام والخاص والمنظمات غير
الحكوميه وغيرها
واعتقدوا ان مسؤوليتنا دول متقدمه تكمن في
توفير الحلول لمن يحتاجونها مثلا
التكنولوجيا الحديثه لتحليه المياه او
لتوفير مصادر طاقه نظيفه واكثر استدامه
اضافه الى وسائل تخزين الطاقه حكاها
مسؤوليتنا هي ان نقوم بالتعاون فيما بيننا
فتراسين مجلس وزراء معظم اعضاء من السيدات
تلعب المراه دور كبير جدا في
فنلندا في الحياه السياسيه همم بتعد في
الهند واحده من اكثر دول العالم تقدما في
المساواه بين الجنسين
عندما ترين ما يحدث في ايران تجاه المراه
والقمع الذي يحدث للمراه هناك ما هو
موقفكم هو افكاركم
بالطبع لدينا موقف ما يحدث للمدنيين في
ايران تصرف خاطئ سواء النساء او فتيات او
اطفال او اي من فئات الشعب ممن يتظاهرون
سلما وهم يتعارضون الاعتداءات النظام ونحن
ندين جميع الانتهاكات في حق المتظاهرين
السلميين نحن نقف الى جانب المراه
الايرانيه ونطالب بالعداله للمراه والفتاه
في كل مكان الحكومه الفنلنديه تديرها خمس
نساء كما لدينا خمسه احزاب سياسيه تراسها
نساء اربعه من هنا في سن الشباب وامهات
ونحن نتعاون معا من اجل بناء المجتمع فيه
المساواه اكثر واحترموا حقوق الانسان
ومتقدم جدا
[موسيقى]
لديها واحد من افضل الانظمه التعليميه ليس
فقط في اوروبا ولكن في العالم كيف يمكن ان
تنقله هذه التجربه الى الدول العربيه هل
تقدموا مثلا اا منح دراسيه اوقف كورس
اكسبريسماس
التعليم في الواقع كانت فيلندا دوله فقيره
جدا قبل نحو 100 عام لكننا عملنا على بناء
دولتنا الحديثه على اساس التعليم
فاستثمرنا اموالنا في ابنائنا فعادت علينا
بالنفع لذلك نرى ان الاستثمار في التعليم
مساله بالغه الاهميه فهي مهمه لمواجهتك
تحديات الجسم التي تواجهنا مثل المناخ
وتراجع التنوع البيولوجي وغير ذلك من
تحديات نحتاج التعليم ونحتاج حلولا مبتكره
وتكنولوجيا حديثه واختراعات جديده من
الذكاء استثمار المال في التعليم لانه
يعود على الدول بالفائده بوجود وظائف اعلى
جوده وارتفاع دخل المواطن وضمان قدره على
تصدير السلع التي صنعتها اعتقد بالفعل انه
من الذكاء الاستثمار بالتعليم كما نود
تقديم يدي العون ولدينا الكثير من
المشاريع مع كثير من الدول بما فيها الدول
الناميه لمساعدتها في بناء انظمتها
التعليميه وهناك الكثير من الامور الاخرى
التي يمكن للعالم ان يتعلمها من فنلندا
في وجود الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وهناك
ازمه طاقه كيف اثرت او تؤثر ازمه الطاقه
على فنلندا وهل لديكم بدائل فوائد
الطاقه نحن دوله مجاوره لروسيا ولذلك كنا
نعد انفسنا على مدى فتره طويله لذلك نحن
لا نعتمد على الوقود الاحفوري الروسي كما
هو حال الدول الاوروبيه عديده كنا نحضر
انفسنا مسبقا لكن ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه اثر
على مجتمعنا ومواطنين وشركاتنا واعمالنا
وهذا يتطلب منا ان نتاكد من اننا نستثمر
في مصادر الطاقه المتجدده واننا سنتمكن من
تحمل الشتاء وليس الشتاء القادمه فقط ومن
ثم العمل على ابقاء اسعار الوقود منخفضه
هذه مساله هنا تعاملوا معها بشكل مشترك
ضمن الاتحاد اوكي لنتمكن من خفض اسعار
الطاقه ومن ثم التعامل مع روسيا وعدم
تمكينها من ان تكون قادره لان تضغط علينا
كما تفعل الان لتبتز اوروبا من خلال
الطاقه
ما هي توقعاتكم مستقبلا او ما هي الحلول
المقترحه في المستقبل القريب لهذه الازمه
انت وورك
لانها تؤثر على كثير من الدول بدرجات
متفاوته والشعب الاوكراني الذي يعيش الحرب
الان يخسروا ارواح الابرياء يوميا ناهيك
عن دول اوروبا الاخرى التي تتاثر بسبب
الطاقه ودول العالم التي تتاثر بسبب
الغذاء فنحن نواجه قضايا كبيره متعلقه
بالامن الغذائي لان روسيا تمنع تصدير
القمح الاوكراني الى خارج البلاد الحرب تؤ
على كثير من الدول باشكال متعدده وعلينا
ان نعمل لضمان وقف الحرب ونحن نساعد
اوكرانيا بكل سبل الممكنه بفرض عقوبات على
روسيا وايصال السلاح لاوكرانيا وللمساعدات
الانسانيه والماليه كما نستقبل اللاجئين
من اوكرانيا ليقيموا في فنلندا ونضمن لهم
حياه افضل
هل انتم مستعدون لاي رد فعل روسي اذا طلب
انضمامكم الى اهميته
وكيف تقيمون رد الفعل الروسي يعني حتى هذه
اللحظه
لكن ليس هناك تهديد عسكري لكل من فنلندا
او السويد او الدولتين اللتين قررتان
الانضمام الى نيته بسبب العدوان الروسيه
على اوكرانيا نحن مستعدون على كافه الصعود
مثل الحرب السبرانيه او الحرب المعلوماتيه
نشهد الكثير من المعلومات المظله المنتشره
على الانترنت نحن لا نتوقع بل نحضر انفسنا
لنكون جاهزين لاكثر من سيناريوكيو
استكمال هذه الحلقه فقط معنا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا ومرحبا بكم في الجزء
الثاني
يوفرها البند الخامس
حقيقي لكننا نود ان يبقى لحالك ذلك في
المستقبل اي انه لو اصبحت روسيا تهددنا
فان دول النيترو ستوب لمساعدتنا في حال
تعرضنا لهجوم ولهذا السبب طلبنا الانضمام
ولا نيته وما كان لهذا الامر ان يكون
مطروحا في فنلندا او السويد لو لم تقم
روسيا بالاعتداء على اوكرانيا فهذا
الانضمام بسبب الحرب والعدوان الروسي على
دوله المجاوره لها ولفلندا حدود طويله
روسيا تبلغ 1300 كم لذلك اردنا ان نضمن ان
ما حدث لاوكرانيا لن يحدث ابدا
كيف تتعاملون مع الرفض التركي او التصلب
التركي ازاء انضمامكم الى حلفنيا
لم تصادق بعد لكنني تحدثت مع الرئيس
اردوغان وقال لي ما قاله علانا انه ليس
لديه مشكله مع فلندا بلديه بعض الامور
التي يعود مناقشتها مع السويد لكن نحن
وسويد معنا في هذا الطريق ونعمل ان تقوم
تركيا والمجر بالمصادقه باسرع ما يمكن
يعني الجانب التركي اتهمكم برعايه همم
الارهاب عبر ايواء عناصر من المعارضين
الاطراف والانفصاليين كيف ترون هذا
الاتهام ايدونس
المتعلقه بالارهاب تعني فنلندا بنفس القدر
الذي تعنيه للسويد لذلك لم نغير تشريعاتنا
ونحن لا نقبل اي شكل من اشكال العنف في
فنلندا
الموقف الامريكي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حليفه لكم
لماذا لم تتدخل برايكم همم مع يعني لماذا
لم تتدخل واشنطن مع انقره همم لحاله الوضع
لكي تتراجع تركيا عن موقفها ازاءكم في
امريكا
بوسعهم ان يجيبوا على هذا السؤال لكننا
بالطبع نعمل مع مختلف الحلفاء والاولاد
المتحده حليف جيد فنلندا حتى قبل تقديمنا
طلب الانضمام للنيتو قبل ايام حددت موسكو
بالرد في الوقت المناسب على نشر الناتو
لقواعد عسكريه في فنلندا كيف ترون وكيف
تردون على هذا التهديد وهل انتم مستعدون
الى اي تهديدات
عضويه كامله باسرع ما يمكن وهذا ما نركز
عليه حاليا ونحن منفتحون لتقبل حلولا
مختلفه اذ نتمتع في فنلندا بتعاون
البرلماني قوي وهو تعون مع الحكومه وكذلك
مع المعارضه هناك اجماع فيما يتعلق
بالسياسات الخارجيه كما لدينا استراتيجيه
رسم سياستنا الخارجيه معا كرئيس وحكومه
وبرلمان بحيث نناقش مثل هذه الامور في
المستقبل ضمن هذه الاليه لكن الاهم الان
يتم الانضمام ومن ثم هذه القضايا لاحقا
الى اندرويد
تتحدثون عن تكامل بين فنلندا والسويد
عسكريا وانه سيرعرضع روسيا قال لك ان
تشرحين
عملنا وتعاوننا مع السويد على مدى فتره
طويله في مجال الامن هذا ليس بالامر
الجديد لكن عضويه نيته ستضيف عمقا لعلاقه
التعاون بين فنلندا والسويد وكاملي منطقه
الشمالي اوروبا
بالنسبه لي مستقبل الحرب نحن نبذل قصار
جهدنا للعمل على انهاء الحرب باسرع ما
يمكن ولسنا مخولين نحن او اي طرف خارجي ان
يحدد كيفيه انهاء هذه الحرب هذا قرار على
اوكرانيا اتخاذه من حيث الشروط التي يمكن
القبول بها ونحن دورنا دعمهم من اجل
التوصل الى قرار فالمهم هو ان لا نتجاوز
بل ان نحاول دعمهم ليتوصلوا الى قراراتهم
المقابله معك الان بعد ان تم تبرئتك مؤخرا
من ارتكاب اي عمل مشين طبعا بسبب الفيديو
الذي توفى العالم كله وانت في احد الحفلات
كيف ترعين هذا ال هذه التجربه وهذا
الفيديو وهذا القرار
هو من يقرر هذا فيديو ما كان مقصودا ان
ينشر علينا فهذه حياتي الخاصه بالطبع لم
يسرني ابدا ان اراه ينشر لكن في نهايه
الامر نحن نعيش في دوله ديمقراطيه هناك حق
الانتخاب الانتخابات المقبله ستكون في
الربيع وعندها سيقرر الشعب رايه بمثل هذه
القضيه لم افعل ما يؤذي منصب رئاسه
الوزراء بل كان وقتي الخاصه والرقص شيء
جميل تقضي فيه وقت فراغك
هل ستغيرين من اسلوب حياتك
نو اي اي سنك سوسو مهمه ان السياسيه في
النهايه هو انسان وانا احب ان اعبر عن
شخصيتي كما هي دون ان اغيرها بسبب المنصب
والشعب يقدر ان تكون على طبيعتك ان يختار
ان كانوا سينتخبونك على هذه الطبيعه او
ينتخبون حزبك ليس مضطرين لاننا دوله
ديمقراطيه انت اصغر رئيسه وزراء في تاريخ
فنلندا توليت في منصبك في عام 2019 وكنتي
في عمر 34 عام
وصفتي باوصاف كثيره وحصوتي على العديد من
الجوائز ولكن ما لفتني هو وصف صحيفه جلد
الالمانيه لك انك اكثر رئيسه وزراء كول في
العالم يعني كيف تعلق يعني
القضايا المطروحه لدينا والازمات الكبرى
التي واجهناها في هذه الحكومه مثل الجائحه
والحرب في اوروبا والان ازمه الطاقه
وربما الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تلوح في
الافق انشغلنا بكل هذه القضايا وهمنا
وانجاز خطتنا الحكوميه انشغالات كبيره
لذلك لا افكر في نفسي بل بهذه القضايا
المهمه
فنلندا
شكرا على هذه المقابله وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا
الكرام على حسن المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]